[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we
are going to be counting down the top 10
unsolved mysteries in Reesie row now
I'll be the first to admit the receiver
wasn't the perfect anime and it did have
some issues with storytelling and tone
shifts in my opinion but I still really
enjoyed it overall and I'm really
excited for season 2 and while a second
season of re0 has not been confirmed yet
we know that there is a huge amount of
buzz around the series we know that
merchandise is selling like crazy so I
think that a season 2 is just a matter
of time and the main reason that I am
excited for our easy row season 2 is
that the first season creates a really
interesting world but it also leaves a
lot of unsolved mysteries that I really
want to see resolved in season 2 and
that is exactly what this video will be
about just a quick warning there will be
spoilers in this video from re0 season 1
but there will not be any spoilers from
the re0 light novel just remember that
here at anime up or we want to be your
number one source for all the latest
news and theories for our easy row
season 2 along with a whole bunch of
other anime series so if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe and be
sure to click that notification bell so
you can be the first to know as soon as
we get some new information and without
further ado mystery number 10
how does Subaru get to the fantasy world
in the first place even though in the
very first episode of re0 Natsuki Subaru
is magically transported into a fantasy
world where the story takes place it is
never actually explained how he gets
there we don't know how exactly Subaru
gets to the fantasy world we don't know
why he is the one chosen and we also
don't know if he is the only one or
perhaps there are multiple people who
have been transported from one world to
another we also don't know if the real
world and the fantasy world are the only
two worlds that exist within reason
or if perhaps there are even more worlds
out there that could be explored so of
course this is a huge mystery it happens
in the very first episode or we 0 but we
still don't have an answer to it and I
really want to find out more about this
in season 2 mystery number 9
why is super was the only person who can
return by death within the world of re0
and why does his save point keep
changing I don't know about you but I
really want to know what is the force
behind Subarus return by that and what
is the logic behind it and also is he
the only one who can return by that with
him that entire world and if so why hand
what makes Subaru so special finally why
does his save point keep changing are
there certain markers or achievements
that he has to unlock before another
save point is reached so that he does
not return by death to the previous save
point but now he returns to a new one
all of these things are really important
to the story and yet we still don't have
any concrete answers which is both
frustrating and kind of intriguing it
makes you really look forward to season
2 and of course if you guys have your
own theories about this or any other
mystery in this video let me know down
in the comments I'd love to hear from
you mystery number 8 who exactly is Elsa
green heart and why was she after
Amelia's insignia in the first place
we know that Elsa is the ruthless and
voluptuous assassin that plays a major
role in the first arc of the story but
after episode 3 she has never heard from
again and it has never explained who she
really is and what she was really doing
now I personally thought that she was a
very interesting character interesting
and she is also a very strong fighter
and a unique type of villain so I wanted
to know more about her but we just don't
see her after the third episode in
season 2 I want to find out who is Elsa
no not that Elsa and I want to know what
is she really up to and who hired her I
definitely hope that she appears again
in reaso season 2 mystery number 7 what
is the deal with the dragon in season 1
over 0 we actually learned very little
about the dragon and I'm really curious
to know why some considered the dragon
to be the protector of the kingdom and
the royal family while others like you
Leo's actually want to kill the dragon
even though he is himself a member of
the nobility the dragon is believed to
have helped seal off the jealous witch
so why would you Leo's want to kill the
dragon does this suggest that perhaps
the jealous which is not all bad
are there more sighs - heard that is
something that I really want to know
this complex relationship between the
dragon the witch and the rest of the
kingdom I really want to find out more
about this in season two mystery number
six speaking of the jealous witch
what is Subarus connection to her why
does he recall her smell and why does
she grasped his heart every time he
tries to reveal to others that he can
return by that also why is super the
only one who can actually see better
versus unseen hands which is a power
that was totally not ripped off from elf
and lead you guys this whole mysterious
connection that Subaru appears to have
with the which is one of the most
interesting things in reezy row and I
really want to know more about this
particular mystery mystery number five
what is Amelia's connection to the witch
why does Amelia look so much like the
jealous witch and is she perhaps
supposed to be a reincarnation of the
witch or something along those lines
vitiligo seems to suggest that amelia is
a potential new vessel for the witch and
that Amelia could essentially become a
vessel that would allow the witch to
return to this world so is that it and
if that is it is it just Amelia who is a
potential candidate or are there other
candidates as well again this is another
one of those really interesting
mysteries in read zero that we just
don't have any concrete answers for but
I really want to find out more in season
two mystery number four is subaru
actually pried the missing sin
archbishop of the witch's cult
we know that subaru has massive problems
with an ego or pride and his fragile ego
causes problems for him throughout the
series we also know that Bethel whose is
somehow able to possess Subarus body
which we thought was only possible with
other members of the witches cold also
known as the fingers so does this mean
that subaru is actually destined to
become one of the sin Archbishop's of
the witches cult is that his connection
to the witch and is that why he was
brought to this world in the first place
this is another really really
interesting question I'm looking forward
to seeing how the writers develop this
aspect of the story we'll Subaru
come a villain in the end will he have a
choice to make the right decision to be
a good guy or a bad guy or is his
destiny going to catch up with him if
that is his destiny in the first place
at any rate very very interesting stuff
mystery number three when the which
tells better is that he is not the one
what does she actually mean by this who
is the one and what is his role in all
of this and is this connected to Subaru
in some way in the last episode of
season 1 Subaru is finally able to
defeat Bethel goose by actually writing
something in the witch's Gospel so does
this mean that Subaru is actually the
one if so what does this mean for the
story and what does it mean for Subarus
connection with the witch and to Amelia
I for one can't wait to find out and
that's why I can't wait for season 2
mystery number 2 why do the MA be such
as the demon dogs in the village and the
white whale who were supposedly created
by the witch centella actually attack
anyone who smells like the witch why
would these beasts be driven to attack
something that smells like their own
creator it doesn't make any sense and it
makes me think yet again that perhaps
the which is a more complex character
maybe there are more side to her maybe
she's not all bad but we'll have to see
and wait to find out and mystery number
one who is brand whose remedy
[Music]
I'm only kidding I'm only kidding relax
enemy recon and black credit guy we all
know who REM is okay mystery number one
is actually who is puck and how is he so
powerful that he can actually destroy
the world if he chooses to in episode 15
we see that puck actually calls Amelia
his daughter and his only reason for
living and he seems to be an incredibly
powerful spirit capable of destroying
the entire world but if he is so
powerful why can't he just protect
Amelia from all danger it's his power
somehow limited by Amelia being alive
but doesn't become unleashed if she died
we just don't know and does Amelia even
know about park's true power like I said
all this talk stuff makes him one of the
most interesting characters for me in
the story and I can't wait to see what
kind of role he and his immense power is
going to play later on in the series
later on in season two personally I
think that spark might be some kind of
crazy necro Godzilla but I'm not sure so
we'll have to wait and find out and
that's it for this video guys I hope you
enjoyed it and let me know down in the
comments which of the mysteries are your
favorite are there some other mysteries
that I missed that you would have liked
to see included and what are some of the
theories you have about these mysteries
what are the answers to these mysteries
let me know down below also be sure to
subscribe for the latest are easy ro and
other anime news and theories and be
sure to click down notification bell so
you can be the first to know every time
we get some news and of course if you
want to chat with us on a daily basis
you can join our discord server link in
the description and until next time see
ya
space cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]